you got a new baby I do beauty what was
everyone has their own take on the
experience of having is this your first
child first baby
yeah he's 15 weeks old Wow and I was a
little disappointed with the customer
service at the hospital at the hospital
people come in and out of the room one
one woman came in she's like I'm gonna
test your baby's hearing now I'm
skeptical right off the bat because my
father is always like thinking he's
getting scammed so you think it's this
scam that they're gonna test your babies
here okay scam is that is that in the
pack we're gonna take them under the
bridge do a little work over the back
what are you talking about the baby
gonna know like how you know the baby
knows right what is she gonna sit there
[Applause]
okay
questioning you're questioning things
that's that's healthy yeah
so you weren't too happy about that part
what else didn't you like another woman
came in she's like it took some
beautiful portraits of your baby we have
an 8 by 10 we got wallets for 2995
my wife's nipples are bleeding and
you're selling me portrait isn't a link
now yeah so that stuff you weren't crazy
but I wasn't crazy about the bath they
gave my baby a bath and aggressive you
know they were
like she's not a Jeep Cherokee tires
with that brush scrub down here well how
has it been having her at home you know
that's the big transition hospitals one
thing then you go home and that's when
that's when things get real it got real
but we are so enthralled with this baby
I mean of course I'm biased the baby is
beautiful and we can't wait till she
gets up in the morning so we get up
before her and we just like kind of sit
there by the crib and she's even looking
at us like can I get another hour
you bunch of creeps looking in over the
crib what are you talking about we just
we love the baby that's great
you